here's a truth true statement i think
i'd rather be watching alone
over anything else in the world
sometimes wow and i think it's just
because i like seeing
how you survive and then i go to bed and
i fantasize about how i would do it it's
the same time every time it's like the
first 48. all right it taps in the
prepper in me or some weird [ __ ] and
people suffer
it's so interesting and they sign up for
it oh i think they win 100 grand
listen to me
you you better be set in traps nets
lines
and have a bow and arrow you better be
doing everything yeah but the people
that go on that show b are like real
outdoors extremists and they still start
and they've done it but like they would
500 grand no camera crews no gimmicks
alone the ultimate test i don't want to
see don't show me that they i have seven
seven seasons to go oh they still starve
they still starve well yeah but they
also what's interesting is
this is their normal they do this on
their own time yeah they're like well
you gave me 500 000. yeah do it yeah i
wanna dude still out there had a seven
bedroom condo man i [ __ ] i can't wear
weeds
it was lit had electricity and [ __ ] damn
yeah do you guys wanna watch tv like
what the [ __ ] yeah
well they'll drop one dude just panicked
one dude in the first season they
dropped me he's a cop from arizona
not prepared and also learn about the
wildlife just learn about it he goes
black bears wolves cougars and more
black bear more wolves more cougars than
anywhere else in north america it's an
island it's i think it's vancouver
island and all they do is live there and
hunt all day like like they're like a
thousand cougars you can hear the wolves
and that's where he they planted it two
black bears the first night two black
bear all right
just sniffing around you know and uh
he's like i'm going home
he was out yeah he goes i'm going home
he calls up the next day he was home if
you like that i'm surprised you don't
like 60 days in i probably will
you know what it is no it's literally
normal people that uh like maybe their
family member or something happen or a
correctional facility officer they've
never been inside prison so for 60 days
they have to go into jail like
jail jail like a nasty jail and they're
undercover
and so they the before they go in like
the you know the sheriff and the person
who runs you know the warden tell them
like you got to get your story straight
because when you're the new guy in there
they're going to ask you
why you're in here and it better be
[ __ ] airtight because they're going
to sniff it out and if they find out
that you're a plant
it's trouble like we got to get you out
of there yeah and then they all have a
sign like they go if you go up because
they know where the camera's at that the
the the crew is watching if you go up
there and you start rubbing your neck we
know to get you out there's a problem
so
there's one guy in there and clearly has
some issues but he was married i think
he had a kid he did 60 days
thriving he's never been to prison i
think his dad was in prison so he wanted
to feel what his dad went through so
he's in there for six days thrives
everyone loves him he's [ __ ] has
friends and they go six days up he goes
i think him and he has a little kid and
a wife and he goes i think i'm gonna
stay another 60 days do another 60.
thriving
because you know what let's stay another
60. you got 180 dude just [ __ ] move
in free free right i love hanging with
the guys yep and you got a kid bro oh
yeah what were you doing yeah this is
the first time he's ever slept good yeah
you got a kid well he gets out after
whatever 80 180 days
commit suicide oh he did
dude if you missed it that bad just
committed a crime and get back in there
oh wait because he hated he hated being
in the real world i don't know clearly
he had some he had problems